So there are two main pathways that are activated during stress response, that
start in the hypothalamus. First is the adrenal medullary system. Now think
back to lesson 1, when I saw the snake. When I initially saw the snake, the
stress was encountered. In my hypothalamus, sends information, to the brain
stem, to activate the sympathetic nervous system. From an evolutionary
perspective, our ability to engage the activation of our fight or flight
response, has important benefits. When we encounter an emergency, or a
dangerous situation, this causes the release of catecholamines and the
activation of our fight or flight response, allow us to behave appropriately.
Meaning, we can either run away or we can stay and fight. So here are the
catecholamines were released and I obviously opted to flee, rather than to
stand and fight. However, long term activation of your sympathetic nervous
system. Can have some serious negative effects. This constant increase in heart
rate, can cause damage, but we're going to talk more about the negative
consequences of chronic stress shortly.